greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn happy new year and
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing skills
so digital marketing
allows business owners regardless of the
business non-profit for-profit large or
small
national local international
to really expand their business
allows them to personalize their content
they could save money and most
importantly they can measure the results
and so that's what we're going to focus
on today we talk about digital marketing
skills focusing on measuring those
results
okay let's switch over to a traditional
marketing channel email marketing you
know one of my favorites you know listen
we're all bombarded with emails
uh
and you know what
it it becomes cumbersome at times i mean
it's easy to just disregard an email and
so to me the key here if you're going to
do email marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope
that that email is relevant to that
audience okay so you need to be able to
really identify
who it is we're sending this email to
and
a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product or your business
then email marketing could be a little
bit of a steeper hill to climb if you
will
but really email marketing is it
involves
emails that promote the brands products
and services
and if you could target the right
audience or making sure you have the
right audience
then you got a good chance of having
successful email marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so
the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copywriting saying the right things but
not saying too much the same time making
the email aesthetically pleasing as
possible so that when somebody does open
the email
they're gonna be able to react to it so
you know writing copy with strong call
to action or really relevant copy that
really talks to the audience i mean
those are all keys for email marketing
in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing
and that's
a b testing and so a b testing is simply
taking an original
and creating a variant and testing the
two to see which one performs
well you could certainly do a b testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if i'm going to send an email to 100
people
i'm going to send 50
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject client and why is this important
because i want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if i see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or
the original subject line then i know
that this subject line works
and therefore i'm going to apply this
subject line moving forward and then
what am i going to do i'm going to take
it and test it against another variant
so you should always do a b testing on
subject lines so the concept of a b
testing should not be lost on any
digital marker okay whether that be seo
search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of a b testing
and of course going back to measuring
results with email you have a different
set of metrics we already mentioned open
rates so if you send out
100 emails
how many people open the email okay you
want that open rate to be as high as
possible and then when they open the
email
the people click on that cta or any of
those links in the email okay so you
want a high click-through rate
and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so what's the engagement
rate
of the landing page from the email
okay so
it's really important that you have an
understanding of all the different
metrics involved with email marketing
and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate
could it be the subject line isn't that
good possibly that's why you have to do
testing if you're getting a low click
they're right on the emails that could
be because the copy may not be that
great or the design or the call to
action or it's not compelling enough for
the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that
okay so you can apply a b testing the
landing page so there are always ways to
react to the data regardless of what
campaign or regardless of what digital
marketing channel
you're working in
so that's the commonality here
one point on email marketing is if
you're going to measure the results of
the campaign whether you're using
you know vertical response or mailchimp
or
you know some other email marketing
platform you want to make sure you have
what we call a utm tracking
and if you're using google analytics
having utm tracking or understanding
what utm tracking is allows you to
measure the results of that email
marketing campaign
in google analytics so that's another
skill set you should have being able to
apply
your tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email
okay because if you don't it's going to
be hard to measure the results in google
analytics hey everyone this is manish
from simply learn and welcome to this
video on email marketing full course in
this whole course we will learn all
about one of the most trendy
technologies today that is email
marketing we will begin this full course
video with what email marketing is and
how to set up email marketing the
benefits of it and a b testing after
this we look into the different types of
email campaigns and how to engage new
users with your emails along with a
hands-on demo using the mailchimp tool
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help every
individual crack an interview
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your email marketing career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have a
experienced email marketing specialist
rob and rahul together we will take you
through the various topics of email
marketing so let's start with an
exciting video on email marketing but
before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn and welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the leads she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers okay so customers
sign up but they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do so how's she gonna
solve the problem of converting the lead
she gets into paying customers well look
no further than email market so you can
boost your sales funnel with the help of
email marketing so email marketing leads
to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your tail i made is a very efficient way
to generate a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our products we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're gonna come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or not sure what
products to buy you know an email can
cover that okay the next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer smooths hydrates and
contains spf 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
talk about purchase the next step in the
life cycle well purchase well with
purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in our
inventory so what do we do we're going
to send an email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're going to give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth 10 dollars for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers key is
the offer is exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that
they help they help the environment they
help the needy okay they care and so we
can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about email
marketing set up so email marketing
setup we have a series of steps that we
need to go through in order to get our
email set up to go ahead and send out to
our target audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create segments so if
you've taken some of my and listen to
some of my webinars in the past about
google analytics about google ads we
talk about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is taking a piece of the
whole so we don't want to email all
users on our list all customers maybe we
want to target a specific segment okay
so we want to be able to identify that
segment who is that segment is it
somebody who or a group of people or
you know a partial list of our customers
who purchase a specific product i would
say so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click send this is a very important step
test that email
before we send and then when we send the
campaigns immediately or we can schedule
a time so
my advice here is always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out the
best time to send that email and then
once the email is sent whenever that is
you want to be able to analyze
performance and there are some key
metrics that you want to hone in on when
we talk about email marketing and some
of those are open rates click-through
rates okay response rate okay so we want
to be able to hone in on certain key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do create our
list add contacts to our list create our
campaign okay we want to select the list
choose a format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to mailchimp
so if i'm in mailchimp basically i'm
going to create a campaign okay
so
it's an email that i'm going to work
with and you can see with mailchimp i
have some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a b test i want
to do a regular email hey i'm just going
to call it test and i'm going to click
begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose our audience okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay we can personalize the
two fields if we want okay so what do we
want to do we want to call people by
their first name their last name the
first and last name or we can customize
it just go with first name to keep it a
little bit personal okay then we have
the subject line here so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting we want to be able to add a
message so we're just going to say and
and subject line is very key here so you
want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with them with them so that they can
open up that email okay so
uh we'll just say have any good day we
can make it better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email
to figure out which one has better open
rates and then with mailchimp we can go
ahead and design the content of our
email so we're going to click design
email okay we can select a template we
have some saved templates already okay
or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there i particularly like
mailchimp because of this very feature
they have a lot of good themes here um a
lot of different layouts that you can
use
okay so you know we're gonna showcase
that product
okay and that's the template we're gonna
use here so here we go we're gonna
showcase our product we're gonna add
that photo of our product here and we're
gonna go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice call to
action we can put our logo up here for
branding again we can edit the content
here so based on that segmented list in
this example
for linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks who bought her
moisturizer before her face moisturizer
and she wants to retarget them she wants
to go ahead and say hey you guys have
bought my product before check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan out who
your audience is you want to plan out
your messaging and you wanna go ahead
and set up the messaging based on that
audience so once you have the messaging
in place voila you're more or less ready
to go okay so
once you get the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign
okay and you can also add a social post
to your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients
okay
customize it
and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're gonna schedule that email
campaign so that's the checklist to go
off okay so remember identify target
audience and create segments and you
create that campaign and in our case we
did set an appropriate call to action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer key
thing here is before we send it out we
want to test that email once everything
looks good we're going to i would advise
schedule it but you can always send the
email when you're ready i would schedule
it at the appropriate time and day okay
so in this case you don't want to send
an email out on a friday afternoon okay
when people are getting ready for the
weekend you certainly don't want to send
an email out over the weekend because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are getting
into the office from a long weekend and
catching up on emails so
from my experience you know tuesday
wednesday depending on your time zone i
would always say you know late morning
early afternoon tends to be a good time
but that's why we have performance
that's why we can analyze performance we
want to be able to see what the open
rates are and the click-through rates
are so that we can make adjustments for
future emails so let's talk about some
of those metrics so when you do send
that email you know we're gonna look at
that open so open rate is the percentage
of the total number of recipients who
open an email so okay so we basically
you know sent it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say you know we sent it to
102 people okay for simplicity sake two
of those emails bounced okay so that
means that we've had a hundred net 100
emails that receive the email and let's
just say 75 open the email okay we wrote
such a good subject line that they
opened it okay that's 75 that's a 75
open rate that's how you measure open
rate click through rate okay so if they
open it we hope that they click on
something and so for all of those emails
that were delivered okay in this case a
hundred how many actually did click on
our call to action so let's just say
75 opened it out of the 100 that's a 75
open rate but of the hundred that
actually were delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked on the
call to action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who opens it but who
clicks on the call to action so that's
click through rate for email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on a link of your email campaign
and actually completed the action so in
our example we're trying to get people
to click on the shopping call to action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails and of the 25 who actually
clicked we had 10 who actually took
action and purchase so 10 divided by 100
is 10
so you have open rate click-through rate
and response rate those are some key
metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line is
so important click their way that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action and then
the response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform mailchimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
april email coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14
open rate 1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better nineteen percent open
two and a half percent on the
click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually were sent how many open it and
how many clicks so this mailchimp makes
it very easy for us to measure you know
open and click rates and then we can
measure by revenue as well based on the
campaign so
that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open rate and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to linda that it's
cost effective it's time saving real
time marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to when we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to meet our
customers needs at the right time it's
less intrusive because we can customize
the emails okay we can as you saw i can
put first name in there to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain credibility when we offer
exclusive offers to repeat customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because you know we could send our
email out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but roi so how many people
from that email went on and purchased so
we can measure that it's very easy to
measure email so let's move into a b
testing so a b testing is key to email
marketing okay so in email marketing
gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
gonna get more people to purchase okay
but it's not as easy as it sounds so how
do we make that possible well we're
gonna do that via a b testing i've
already mentioned it when i set up my
example campaign in mailchimp i stressed
and stressed and stressed that we need
to have two subject lines go out per
email okay so before i stress that again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b testing is a method to
analyze which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective in terms of
high open rates and click rates okay so
in this case an a b testing you can send
out two emails you can send out two
subject lines you can send out two call
to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example i talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so i wrote a
subject line i don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
i write a second subject line then i'll
be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up two
different subject lines likewise for
email content so the subject line and
email content are the most important
elements so we want to be able to test
them if they're interesting intriguing
uh attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b test where linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's going to
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a higher open rate okay so
in our example here linda sends version
a of the email to 50 of the recipients
with the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate
well version b which is sent to the
other 50 percent has the subject line
three important strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is three and three the number three
spelled out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now be able
to measure the success of that a b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate numbers always
tend to work in subject lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
50
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow and
version b to the remaining fifty percent
eighty dollars today ninety dollars
tomorrow and the only really succinct
difference here is using the word but
versus a comma and she sent that email
out and that email went out and the
data's coming in and she's going to
measure the success of that a b test
well version b has the higher open rate
you know we want to be short
succinct and stay away from those
conjugations like but okay it tends to
have a negative connotation so the
shorter more direct email our subject
line 80 today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 with the subject
line uh-oh your prescription is expiring
version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder which one you think will perform
go ahead and put your comments right
below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a b test okay so she sent
the email out two different subject
lines fifty percent got one subject line
the other fifty percent got the other
subject line and it just so happens
version a uh oh your prescription is
expiring there's a little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring seems to be a little bit more
you know command-ish hey your
prescription's expiring so we expect you
to purchase where you have a little uh
oh in front it's like hey you know i
think your prescription is expiring
maybe you should think about renewing it
okay i think that's how that's
interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates so in order
to keep improving those open rates you
need to continue and not continue should
always do subject line testing always
because one subject line is always going
to have a better open write than the
other so always do a b testing when it
comes to subject lines and email content
for that matter okay so we're always
going to do continuous a b testing so
with continuous a b testing we can test
very various elements of the email so
you can always test the sender's name
the subject line the copy the call to
action the design the imagery there's a
lot of different elements you can test
with emails for example
sender's name okay so you want to
personalize it as much as you can okay
you don't want to do a no reply you want
it to come from a human being in this
case sam okay at least that's what i
think let's see what the test states no
surprise version a has the higher open
rate if you customize these things and
personalize them then it goes a long way
sending an email from a no reply is not
a good
best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar increase your email open rates
webinar increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic that's going to you
know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy so learn some
easy ways to increase your email open
rates join us on may 10 2019 7 p.m for
an interactive discussion with our
experts well version b is more
personalized it's a same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case rachel so we can
measure the success of the a b test but
it's no surprise that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's going to increase click rates so we
can also test that call to action the
difference here is coloring save my seat
yellow versus save my c blue again go
ahead and play along here if you're
watching this go ahead and add a comment
and just see if you're right do you
think it's blue or you think it's yellow
on the call to action color does go a
long way in email marketing so let's
measure the success of this a b test and
it just so happens yellow is going to
perform better why does yellow perform
better than blue what's more positive
plus it it kind of resonates a little
bit stronger and easier okay it stands
out a little bit better it's not as
pastely and dull as this shade of blue
we're using so you can see here we're
testing every bit of the elements of the
email anything from the from to the
subject line to the message to the call
to action and so at the end of the day
you know you want to be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results so we're going
to send that out the entirety of the
email and we could see version a looks a
lot better and why does version a look a
lot better in this example because look
at the font size is a little bit bigger
version b font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them you know 48
points or 50 points and plus you know 14
versus 12 goes a long way we can
continue testing we can test imagery you
can see here we have a hand aligned with
the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version b has the other
type of hand aligned with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version b
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name then
we move to a subject line then we move
to personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line gotta personalize the email to
rachel with larger font okay we got a
nice call to action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sent out an
email last month with the subject line
about you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
percent people resonate with emojis
especially if they're positive emojis
okay so we want to personalize those
subject lines for better open rate okay
when i say personalize don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested uh
oh just putting uh oh in there made it
sound like we actually cared it was a
little bit personal it wasn't so
personal you weren't dressed in a
specific person but one little word goes
a long way in a subject line because
when people get emails and they read
emails and a lot of people are inundated
with emails the subject line is what
they're reading first and just by
personalizing it adding a number adding
an emoji just making it positive and
easy to read they're likely to open that
email so personalized email messages can
improve click through rate and open
rates as well so you want to personalize
your email as much as you can whether
that be from the from field to putting
that person's name in the salutation so
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
percent so don't come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines so title case subject
lines for example when i say title case
game of thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much of course if you go with lowercase
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and somebody's probably not
going to open it so you always go with
that title case the every initial letter
gets capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within 17 17 and
24 characters so according to campaign
monitor the ideal length of a subject
line is up to 24 characters and they're
more likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short but make it
impactful make it personalized like i
mentioned before if you get too long
then it may get cut off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend keeping it up to about 24
characters okay if you go over by a
couple characters not the end of the
world but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency we mean sense of
urgency meaning if that coupon is going
to expire
you want to let people know it's going
to expire that day or the next day or
within a few days okay so you can use
things like hurry up or limit offer or
limited stock or offer expires on okay
so add a bit of sense of urgency i mean
the sky's not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring at the end of the week
you probably want to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up so let's talk about optimizing
your email content so we focused a lot
on subject lines let's talk about the
email content itself so some ways to
optimize email content are we want to
send the content that is relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation we want to use
bullet points to make the content
readable we want to follow logical
structure we want to use compelling
imagery and prefer design emails with
responsive designs and what we mean by
responsive design is hey most people are
going to be checking that email on their
mobile phone okay so
make sure when you design the email it's
also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes go
ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on testing your
email before you actually send it and
when you actually send an email test
email don't send it to yourself send it
to colleagues you know send it to
another group a fresh set of eyes a
fresh set of eyes like it's going to be
able to pick out that misspelled word
that you overlooked so i can't stress
the sending of the test email because
it's going to be able to you know in a
way ensure that you're doing everything
on this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes you know the person who's
receiving your test email your colleague
at work may be looking at that email on
their mobile phone and if it doesn't
look good to them they're going to let
you know some other ways to optimize
email content personalization so we did
that on the a b testing you always want
to personalize it question is hey do i
use first name do i use first and last
name well guess what you can test that
but you want to personalize it okay you
want to choose the right fonts and
colors for your email so
when we were going through some examples
on testing you know i always tend to go
a little bit larger on the font but you
could play around with it i don't think
you should probably use white lettering
on a black background that just is not
very good or best practice but go ahead
and try it if you want okay you can
always play around and test these but
you want to choose something that's
really going to resonate with the
recipient of the email okay you want to
build a rapport with customers by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about you know
sharing with them some of the
non-profits that we work with as a
company okay if we have a you know
cosmetics company and we have different
products like moisturizers and facial
creams we may
want to state that hey we don't use any
animals in the testing of these products
you know we're pro animal we're not you
know we're not going to use animals in
the testing of our products and that
probably resonates with a lot of your
customers so you want to go ahead and
build a rapport with those customers by
sharing those insights okay and use
recipient names and you always want to
personalize it then add a clear call to
action at the end you always want to
have that call to action regardless of
what the email is hey it could be just a
simple read more or hey donate it
doesn't have to always be so hardcore in
terms of hey purchase our product that
could be a turn off especially if you're
sending emails out once a week to your
customer base they're constantly
hammering them with buy now buy now by
now they're going to get turned off so
you want to mix up the call to actions
and that goes back to the very first
step and what kind of email are you
going to send out and who are you going
to send it to so you have to align those
two with somebody who doesn't even know
who your brand is you're not going to
put a call to action of buy now you're
probably going to say hey check us out
we have some cool stuff for you okay
let's talk about automating emails email
automation so triggered emails are sent
to customers based on an event date or
user behavior okay so when we say an
event could be a special occasion like
mother's day okay could be a date like a
birthday or anniversary or specific day
of the week could also be based on user
behavior you know a good example of user
behavior are those who abandon the car
you can trigger an email in fact
mailchimp has remarketing functionality
so with mailchimp hey if somebody
abandons our car we can have an email
triggered and we can send an email a
nice email that says hey we noticed you
didn't finish purchasing our product and
i'm not sure what happened but hey
here's another 10 off or you can always
just make product recommendations as
well but you want to react to user
behavior and use emails to your
advantage for that so you want to take
be cognizant of different occasions you
want to be cognizant of special events
holidays etc and user behavior so these
types of emails can be automated because
you know when they might happen or that
they are probably going to happen so
auto responder emails are sent at
frequent intervals based on the behavior
of subscribers so for example if
somebody purchases something then you're
going to get an email that probably says
hey thank you for your purchase another
email that says hey your product's on
its way and then another email that says
hey your package your product has been
delivered so that's an example of an
automated email it goes out if somebody
purchases your product you probably want
to thank them for that and then you
probably want to let them know that hey
it's on its way here you could track it
and then again you want to confirm that
it's been delivered but thank them again
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out okay let's talk
about types of email campaigns so we
have different types of email campaigns
and the first is a newsletter so with
email newsletters subscribers are
connected and informed about product
updates so it doesn't necessarily have
to be a product they buy it could be a
product they subscribe to like software
okay you always want to be able to send
out that newsletter to let them know
what's going on with your product are
there upcoming product updates ahead is
there one that just happened is there a
webinar that discusses the new product
update so that's what the newsletter is
going to do inform the end user about
the update so how to optimize okay so
you stack your email content create a
compelling header share different
variety of useful content like videos
articles etc with those recipients and
then follow a consistent schedule so
that's how you handle a newsletter you
should always create a compelling header
but if you're going to send a newsletter
make sure you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that will follow
up on what you put in the email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product update so
example here is a newsletter that gets
sent out and here you can see it talks
about business process it's got some
nice imagery in there okay call to
action it's got a little bit of
everything in this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking you can see at the top it's got
work with the industry best subscribe
now okay they validate that with 25
years of top notch service then they
talk about hiring the best talent and
you got the next bit of content below
that so that's stacked email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling hatter and then they're going
to share a variety of different content
in there like there could be clicks in
there to video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on if it's personalized then you
can say hey
so and so we know you're a mother here
take 20 off i mean that kind of
personalized email with an offer goes a
long way
here you an example from toms limited
time extra 20 off all styles they
include the code in there okay again you
can see the the sensitivity and the
sense of urgency with the limited time
another email campaign type and
personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart so abandon card emails i
like working with abandon card emails
because you know we want people to
purchase and as much as you try on your
email marketing campaign to drive
traffic to the website and as hard as
the website works to get people to
convert through the shopping cart it's
never gonna be a hundred percent and so
abandoned cart emails give us that extra
incentive
to get that person back to the shopping
cart to purchase okay so these emails
are shared with customers who have added
product to their cart but didn't finish
through the checkout process in other
words they didn't purchase the product
so it's an effective way of sales
recovery it gives us another opportunity
to reach out to that person who just is
almost there but not quite ready to
finish the purchase so what are we going
to do we're going to send out an email
for those that abandon their car and
we're going to use a simple abandoned
cart email template okay you want to be
simple here you don't want to get
complicated we're trying to make this
easy for them to finish purchasing the
product so we want to definitely
personalize it okay we want to send a
series of email reminders okay in your
email reminder add a product image so as
customized as it can be it could be even
the product image of what they've
abandoned and that's the best practice
so
if it's that facial moisturizer that
linda's trying to promote and she can't
quite get enough people to finish
purchasing the product they're they're
banning the cart well she can certainly
send out the abandoned cart email okay
so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly it's a gentle reminder okay so
come across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so-and-so twenty
percent off on your cart valid until so
and so offer on your favorite product so
the first email that went out and the
series of emails hey you forgot
something hey is there anything we can
do to help you complete the product
purchase email too is just that gentle
reminder hey you're selling out quickly
you might want to purchase that product
and the email three is to really help
them along by saying hey here's 20 off
valid until so and so so just a small
series of emails that go out try and get
somebody back into the shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so in a re-engagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to inactive
email subscribers so what it does is it
boosts engagement and helps to maintain
a high inbox placement ratio inbox
placement ratio so we want to be able to
make sure that we're getting people back
on our subscriber list so how we gonna
optimize for something like this this is
you know these are difficult type of
email campaigns we're trying to
re-engage with people who are inactive
so we want gamification to re-engage
subscribers or we want to prefer subject
lines like hey we've been missing you or
did we do something wrong okay we can
run a poll or competition to re-engage
with our subscribers so for example hey
we'd hate to miss your birthday go ahead
and update your account this is a
starbucks email so we'd hate to miss
your birthday so it's that you know
message of missing you you can always
soften or sweeten the deal with an offer
as well so that brings us to how to
engage with new subscribers so we just
talked about re-engaging with inactive
we want to talk about engaging with new
subscribers so how to engage with new
subscribers well thank your subscribers
for joining okay create clear and
compelling subject lines that is a must
regardless of what type of email you
send out you always want to send out
that compelling subject line okay
noticed the good examples within 17 to
24 characters know the ideal time to
message okay again sending it on the
weekends not going to work okay sending
it out during the weekday
you know in the morning mid-morning you
know sometimes in the afternoon works
really depends on who your audience is
but weekends probably aren't going to
work okay avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally you know let them
know that the email's coming from a real
person okay because if it doesn't come
from a person most people aren't going
to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you straight with people who are
new they don't know your brand they
don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again
personalization always personalize if
it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link i can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to
unsubscribe even if it was a good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription so you always
want to include that unsubscribe link in
fact in the united states it's actually
law so there is regulation about that
around that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there i use
mailchimp i've used a few in the past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them again
mailchimp marketo marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
hubspot convertkit send in blue aweber i
mean these are just some of the many
that are out there okay so let's show a
demo again of an email marketing
campaign so
let's show an example of a newsletter
that
one of my clients had sent out and so
this is paul eckman group paul ekman dr
ekman inspired the tv show lied to me so
well known in the industry of micro
expressions he's the form mentioned
expert in micro expressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns and he
sends out a monthly newsletter so this
is a newsletter was sent out in november
2018 and if we look at it you can see
here okay it's stacked content nice
imagery okay respectful disagreements
how to deal with disagreements this
holiday season so really relevant
personalized because and timely because
it was set in november during the
holiday season so got some nice imagery
there okay we got content in here and
then right below that on the stack
content what do we have final hour 24
hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in to
the email then here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an example of a
micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use microexpressions
to your advantage so call to action here
then we have some more information here
with the learn more so a newsletter that
went out basically really a blog post
built into the email with some nice
content reminding folks hey they have 24
hours got some other useful information
in the email so this email went out very
timely 98 000 okay see subject line here
controversy respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving okay could the subject line
be a little bit shorter yes possibly but
if we look at the open rate 15
16 open rate okay industry average in
education and training is 18
okay so they're close to the industry
average on the click rate you know 1.6
percent on the click rate industry
average 2.1 so we can see what the top
links were clicked okay so they have a
lot of links and and mailchimp will help
you measure what links were clicked the
most who subscribed what subscriber with
the most opens we can see opens by
country but that's an example of a
newsletter for this particular company
okay stacked content okay sense of
urgency okay you can see the subject
line timely newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email for the time of year okay so let's
go over the checklist again for email
marketing so good reminders on the
checklist this is a checklist you want
to make sure
all boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rates direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure not only is it personalized
but the name aligns with the email
address okay should always personalize
always personalize the subject line and
the email copy text meaning you know
don't just say hello say hello to sally
pete rob
michael etc always include an
unsubscribe link in emails and give
people the option to unsubscribe okay
you can always re-engage them another
way or later on but you don't want to
irk any one of your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar there's lots of
different elements we can test from
subject line to content to font to call
to action to imagery to subject line etc
there's no shortage of elements in an
email you can test you want to use
welcome emails to build good customer
relationships so when somebody signs up
for a newsletter send out a welcome news
email to them hey welcome thank you for
signing up you should always segment
your list based on user behavior so you
have a group of people who purchase
product a customize your email for
product a but you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is so you can talk to your
audience okay and you can always ask
your subscribers to update their
preferences as well because you want to
make sure you're sending out emails to
the right person write address okay this
is a
short checklist now we can expand upon
this but these are some of the most of
the key items when it comes to email
marketing some other items on the
checklist include features such as
countdown timers and live polls okay
make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week once a
week is probably as much as you want to
go depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something then you probably
want to send an email thanking them for
the purchase another one letting you
know the product has been shipped and
another one with thank you the product
has been received reward those
subscribers send out exclusive offers
okay make sure your emails are optimized
for mobile that means send out test
emails and check it on different devices
create a schedule okay you can automate
these emails so create a schedule
that makes the most sense have a footer
and header in the email and in that
footer and header is going to be some
information okay just like i showed you
with the microexpressions there was a
footer and header avoid spam filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices and don't have
spammy subject lines have an actual name
associated with the reply to email and
split up your list as well when you send
out one email to 150 000 people it could
probably get caught up in some spam so
segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging can be
specific to the audience that's going to
help avoid spam and then of course you
always want to measure and analyze
results so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms have the results
built in especially open rates and click
rates we're going to talk about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp as your email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp so the first thing you need to
do is sign up for an account with
mailchimp and that's simply just
providing an email address an id and a
password and i recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with a free plan first and let's take
a look at what the feature plan features
are for mailchimp so i'm recommending
the free plan but when you actually sign
up you have the option to actually pay
for a plan so you have the essential the
standard the premium or the free and so
i recommend you go with the free version
first it's like buying a car you want to
test drive it out see if you like it see
if you like the features and benefits
and you can see here that with the free
plan you get a lot of features and
benefits so you get all the basics for
businesses that are just getting started
so if you're just getting started with
email marketing i would recommend the
free plan here because you have a 2 000
contact maximum so that means you can
send out an email to your 2 000
recipients free of charge so not a bad
deal for businesses who are starting out
i mean if you are prepared you've used
mailchimp before then go ahead and sign
up for one of the paid versions each
version has a different set of standards
a different set of features and benefits
from the essential all the way up to the
premium where you're gonna get you know
advanced features um and more
customization but that's 299 dollars a
month if you're not prepared to pay that
amount then my recommendation start with
that free plan now when you actually do
set up your account you're just gonna
again provide a id email address and
password you're gonna go through a
couple of steps and one of these steps
that i would recommend you do right away
is connect your facebook and twitter
accounts so if you already have a
facebook and twitter account very simple
all you're doing is authorizing
mailchimp to connect to the account and
the reason for that is when you actually
connect your twitter facebook account
you'll be able to then you know share
content on those platforms and mailchimp
will do that for you automatically okay
so here you're just asking it to
more or less interact with the platform
social platform and i recommend doing
that as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do if you're
already logged into your twitter
facebook account all you need to do is
click on the plus button as you go
through the setup wizard and authorize
mailchimp to access your twitter or
facebook account here you can see what
mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to retweets
from your timeline post tweets for you
on your behalf if you want them to if
you want them to you're going to allow
mailchimp to see create and manage your
advertising data including the campaigns
and audiences and the reason for this is
you may
you know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts with your social media
efforts and the great thing about
mailchimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from facebook and twitter and
integrate them with mailchimp you'll be
able to so having these two platforms in
the case of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but i recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template just by default
you could pick one just to get the
account going but you can always go back
and add or change out the template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i arbitrarily just chose a template
i can go back and choose some of the
templates that are available to me now
again you can create your own template
if you want to okay so you just click
create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a you know template that you can
pretty much change and customize so if
you're thinking about sending out an
email with an announcement then that's
the type of template you want to choose
and so here now you can see we have a
logo we can change the announcement here
we can add photos etc so if i want to
add my logo i'm just going to go up to
this top portion here click that little
pencil icon that will allow me to edit
here you can see it's default logo i
don't really have a logo so i can say
replace it i can also link to it and
here you can see in the content studio
of mailchimp i don't have any images to
choose from so i'm going to go ahead and
upload one and i'm going to go ahead and
upload my logo that i've had on my
desktop okay so it's going to upload and
now i can select that and insert it so
now i have my logo as part of my
template here and
you can also see you can add some
styling here to this hot header part so
i can add a nice border around that okay
so i can align its center i can go edge
to edge okay so i can customize the
image in this particular template here
so i'm just going to click save and
close now i'm ready to move on to the
next part which is just click on edit i
want to make an announcement okay share
your big news okay we're
having a launch party okay so here you
can see again just in this template this
quote unquote announcement template i'm
able to just make changes to each
section now i'm in the section of the
announcement part where i can now
customize the text and you can see i can
you know bold it you know i can choose a
different font go aerial i can choose
the size you can make it smaller larger
pretty easy to use i could again style
it with different color and so i can
make multiple columns here if i want to
so there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well so let's go ahead
and just do one more thing here let's
maybe color or something i mean you can
see i can add a link let's go ahead and
make it blue that's the background so i
want to change the background so i'm
just going to click ctrl z i'll change
the color of the font itself there you
go very simple and easy to use now i can
add photos here if i want to so let's go
ahead and edit this bottom part here so
i'm going to click again the edit icon
okay so here you can see i have three
images in the template i'm going to go
ahead and add to that so here i can go
ahead and upload some files so i have
some files waiting for me on my desktop
i'm just going to go ahead and add them
and upload them to the content studio
and now that i've uploaded them i can
select one of them to insert okay now
i'm going to go here insert the second
one and now i'm going to grab the third
one and insert that in its place here
you can see now i can go ahead and you
know style each one of these if i want
to okay i can add a border again okay i
can go ahead and do rounded corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical i can do
this so i have a lot of flexibility
and
what i add to these particular you know
templates okay this is again just the
announcement template and so now i'm
going to click save and close and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i could play
around with the design and header and
once i'm done really if i'm happy with
my email i can just close it out and i'm
done so what i could do now is when
you're done with this template you can
just preview and test it so i could send
a test email or enter preview mode so if
i enter preview mode this is what the
template i chose is going to look like
if i happen to send it out okay this is
what it looks like on desktop this is
what it looks like a mobile and if i go
inbox preview i'll need to upgrade my
account because i'm on the free version
so but i can certainly see what it looks
like on mobile on desktop so i'm just
going to click out of that and this is a
template and so i can go back and edit
this anytime i want so when i'm done i'm
just going to go ahead and click the
mailchimp icon in the upper left it's
going to ask me to
name my template so i'm going to name
this the announcement template i'm going
to click save and now it's in my
templates so i'm free to use this
template anytime i'm ready to send an
email okay and again i can you saw how
easy it was to make a change in the
template itself so when i'm ready to use
the template i can just go ahead and
grab it okay and again i can go ahead
and style it and design it any way i
want so you have different sections of
the page that you can style and here you
got you know mobile style designs if you
wanted to now if you wanted to in the
template if i want to like duplicate the
whole block i can duplicate that whole
block and you can see it just copied it
or i can just get rid of it it's a very
easy to use
wysiwyg if you will or interface it
allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again i'm
working with a template here so anytime
i'm ready to use that template for an
email i can go in and start using it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
going to find my template here i can
always edit it i can always share it i
can always preview it i can replicate it
and that's the important thing so if i
rapidly i'm basically creating a copy of
it okay so i just created a copy so now
if i wanted to create a or change the
copy of it i can do that so if i don't
like this whole block i can just delete
it and now that i'm done i can rename
this i'm just going to say announcement
template v2 so now it's been renamed and
now i have two templates just simply by
choosing one and replicating it so again
if i go back to templates here here i go
i have my two templates and i can store
these in a folder so i'm going to add a
folder i'm going to call it
announcements and i'm going to add the
folder and that's it so now i can store
these in the folder so you can organize
all your templates in different folders
if you want to so i'm going to take
these two templates here move them to my
announcements folder and there you go
they're in the announcements folder so
if you're going to create multiple
templates then i would recommend you go
ahead and organize it create folders you
know and set up as many folders as you
want and need because you're going to
probably have different templates for
different occasions depends on what type
of email you're sending out so i just
chose arbitrarily an announcement type
email so now if i go back to create
templates okay you could see again let's
go through some of these others again i
just chose make an announcement you
could tell a story follow-up educate
you got all sorts of different templates
that you could choose all sorts and here
you got some themes so you can even go
with a theme if you wanted to so for
example if you're selling products let's
just say you have a boutique store let's
just choose this boutique template if i
choose this here is my themed template
and so now
just like the other template i was
working in i can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top i got the
middle section you know i got all these
different sections that i can now go
ahead and edit so just about really it's
about choosing a theme template that
works best for you and feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you so
here you can add in certain things like
you know social share so if i just drag
and drop i can add in a social share
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do in
terms of the design in terms of the
content so again if you go back and i'm
going to cancel not save this temp well
let's save it we'll call it boutique we
may use it again in the future so i'm
going to go ahead and click save and now
it's a template it's going to be located
in templates and again if you always
want to access templates just go to
templates you'll see the templates that
you already have created and added so
you can edit them always just by
clicking the edit button now that's
again if you want to create a new
template just create click on the create
new template call to action again you
got themes you've got layouts or you can
even create your own from scratch you
can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch and html so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation i like some of
the layouts that mailchimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one
again you're in full control of how to
design and message it so you're in full
control of that so if you just want to
again tell a story i'm going to select
this template here okay now i'm on the
free version so keep in mind with the
free version i don't have access to all
the templates so here i get to upgrade
to use this one but for example if i
don't see the message upgrade to use
then i'm free to grab it so you can see
the one column i'm free to use so i'm
just going to select that and now i have
this template available to me so again
i'm free to edit this one as i see fit i
mean i can go ahead and again drop in
any one of these elements that are
available to me here i'm going to drop
in my social block okay so here you can
see i can now customize my social block
if i want to add in another platform i
can do that social media platform click
save and close so you can see they're
very customizable all of these themes
and layouts are very customizable and
again when you're done it's just a
matter of you can preview it or test it
you can enter preview mode or you can
send yourself a test email okay if you
send yourself a test email you can
actually see how it looks when it comes
in so let's go ahead and do that here so
i'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email has been sent so
let's go check our inbox so here is the
email that
i just created from the theme you can
see here all i did simply when i edited
i just dropped in my social block in
here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about mailchimp
is they have an option that you can view
the email in a browser if you can't or
you know don't want to look at it in
your in this case i'm looking at gmail
so you can always or recipients can
always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific now when it comes to
completing your profile on mailchimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into mailchimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see i already have one contact
that contacts me because i added my
email address on that test email so
mailchimp is smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're gonna add them so
here we can see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if i click on
import here i'm going to be asked to
import either from a csv or copy and
paste or i can just go ahead and
integrate it so if i choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context i have there and so
it's up to you how you import your
contacts now the whole point of contacts
is you want to probably or really not
probably it's a best practice to
actually create different lists so that
you can use different audience lists
with different emails
and so here you can see i have one email
address i can again import contacts or i
can add them individually so i can add
subscribers here okay that's another
option that's the slower option my
recommendation be import them but when
you import make sure you you're
importing lists that have some
commonality so you can manage those
lists so if you have one list that are
say
you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way i would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp that allows you to
you know build out your audience just by
using one of their forms so again we
have a subscriber pop-up you've probably
seen some of these on some of the
websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example all you need to do is enter
in their email address and click
subscribe okay that's the the pop-up
version now again you have the
opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here or an embedded
form okay or you can integrate the form
okay so if i click form integrations
here i can use wufoo or squarespace i
can integrate with them if i go back to
signup forms if i choose form builder
here i have a signup form and then i can
customize that form with different boxes
okay or fields okay so whatever field i
want somebody to add information to i
can have that in there and then this
form could be you know on your website
so that's a great feature about
mailchimp is it helps you build an
audience so i can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form is going to be added to
my subscriber list that i can use for
future emails to take that a step
further i can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if i click on audience i can
go ahead at the bottom right here i have
an option to create a landing page so if
i click on that just like everything
else in mailchimp it's fairly easy to
use i'm just going to name it test click
begin here i can choose my audience
again i can what audience do i want to
add these emails to i click begin and
i'm going to accept and here now i have
all these different templates that i can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so i can customize it just
like i do with my email template i can
add my logo okay i can start adding
different fields here like an image i
can drop an image here okay i can go
ahead and
you know drop in my social shares okay i
can drop in a box text box okay and then
i can start customizing it with some
text some imagery you know some other
information again this is a landing page
that i can then add to my website and so
anytime somebody goes to the landing
page and fills out their email address
and hits subscribe it's going to be
added to that audience list and then i
can turn around and send an email using
one of mailchimp's templates to that
audience so mailchimp really does a
great job
of allowing you to grow your list within
your own website via a landing page a
form submission or or forum or pop-up so
there are lots of different options
available to us so i'm going to click
save and close here and now this landing
page is available to me so i can
customize the url i can edit the
audience that these emails go to i can
add a page title and again i can edit
the design so i can really make this an
integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website i can add a specific
url and i can add a nice page title to
it so mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on facebook or
google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in mailchimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if i click on
content studio here here you can see the
files i've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you can certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giffy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have instagram so what
you can do is you can integrate you know
any one of your instagram accounts if
you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your mailchimp account and when you
do that it's going to pull in all the
images that you've had on instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending down emails you're gonna have
the option to look at reporting to see
how those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see
how we fared on some of our emails okay
so for example if i sent out an email
here in april and this is april 2019 i
could see how many total subscribers
i've had now along with the number of
subscribers you have you have what we
call open rate and click-through rate
now we explain a lot of the reporting
and the specific email metrics and
another recording that we did last week
so if you're interested in learning more
about some of the metrics then check out
the video that we have on youtube email
marketing tutorial uh we recorded this
last week go into details about all the
different metrics you
uh can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in mailchimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with mailchimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we could see in this particular
email last year in april you know we've
had 14 14 1.1 percent to be exact and
that is 13
377 divided by 97 469 so that's how many
people open the email so 13 000 out of
97 is about 14
now when somebody opens it we hope
they're going to click on it and so here
we got a
1.4 percent click-through rate again
that's the total number of clicks based
on the total number of subscribers or
people that were sent the email and so
mailchimp just gives you a nice overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular audience list and then the
open rating click rate so we can really
dive in here and we can actually see how
that particular email performs so if we
just pick one email here we can just
click view report we have other options
here we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email look like we can select that so we
just want to view the report so we're
going to click view report and now we
can get into
some nice detailed information about the
actual report itself so again here you
can see total number of recipients and
this came from the audience list called
newsletter okay was delivered last year
september 26 2018 again i have the
option to view it download it print it
or share it so let's take a look and
view the email to see what it looked
like okay so this is what the email look
like we have our own template here and
here you can see it takes into account
some of the best practices involved with
email marketing you know we have some
nice content imagery some call to action
here some other links okay we have our
social icons okay so that's what the
email looked like okay so we'll go back
and we're going to click view report now
we want to view the report again here's
what it look here's when it was sent
okay the open rate for this was 21
click-through rate was four percent so
for us the list average this list here
newsletter the average was for the open
rate 16.8
so we're above the average on this email
for the click-through rate the list
average is 2.7 so we're above the
average so
we've done a good job on this email at
least generating more opens more clicks
and mailchimp even takes that a step
further they'll even show you what the
industry average is for your particular
industry and in this case we're
education and training so we did better
than the industry average for both the
open rate and for the click-through rate
so we could see some other specifics we
could see the raw numbers of opens
clicks how many people bounced meaning
the email address wasn't valid anymore
and so mailchimp does a good job of any
email that actually bounces it'll be
scrubbed and removed from your list and
then here you can see 347 unsubscribe so
the the thing about you know mailchimp
is we want to be careful we don't have
too many unsubscribes and also people
abusing or reporting abuse meaning you
don't want to send out an email multiple
multiple times a week where it gets the
point where it's spammy and so you want
to avoid a high number of unsubscribes
and a high number of abuse reports and
so here you can see
most emails are open within a 24-hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within 24
hour period okay so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's going to
tail off from there great thing is
mailchimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so i
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here
whether you use mailchimp or you use any
other platform whether that be vertical
response or any other type of email
marketing platform you want to use utm
tracking with your links so that google
analytics can pick up the actual
campaign so here you can see we have utm
tracking appended to our links and let
me just go in to detail on that for just
a minute so mailchimp again gives us
nice data on open and click-through
rates but when we send out an email and
people actually do click on one of these
links they're going to go to our website
and from there google analytics is going
to take over on the tracking so this is
as far as mailchimp goes so we want to
be able to bridge the gap between
mailchimp reporting and google analytics
meaning when they came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking which is simply
appending the original url with some
tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do when you set up a
mailchimp campaign is just go to url
builder in google then you're going to
click on campaign url builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign so for example if we go back
here this was the original url so if i
just copy this original url here and
paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm going to
put mailchimp with my medium i'm going
to put email so mailchimp is the source
of where the traffic came from the
medium the means in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
the campaign name we're just going to
put maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the url and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here i can see mailchimp
email summer promo and then for the
content i can use that to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original url
with a new url appended with utm
tracking so if i copy that i can simply
just paste that in my browser just to
see if it works and here you can see it
works the page loaded the original url
with utm tracking and so that's exactly
what you want to do because when you're
looking at your reports in mailchimp
it's going to show me the top links that
were clicked now if i go into analytics
i want to be able to see how that
campaign or how that link actually
performed so let's take a look at that
real quick so if i go to my google
analytics account and i go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am i looking for well if i click on
source and medium source and medium are
to the parameters for utm tracking i'm
going to look for mailchimp so here i
can see
my original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp and then the medium's email
so if i go back here i can see for
example any one of these mailchimp
emails that went out and then i can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the balance rate was meaning
if they arrived on the site did they
leave after arriving or they actually go
to another page and then i could see
other engagement data like how many
pages they looked at did they how much
time did they spend more importantly did
they convert so that's the whole idea
behind using utm tracking because with
utm tracking you can can bridge the gap
from open rate click through rate to
behavior on the website all the way
through to the conversion and that's
what we want to measure we want to
measure did somebody go from the email
open it click on one of the links go to
the website engage on the website and
convert and so that's the whole idea
behind utm tracking because mailchimp
and any other email marketing platform
is only going to give you at most your
open rates and your click-through rates
okay so here we could see the top links
clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site and now i need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here i can see what subscribers had
the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your twitter
account or your facebook account you'll
be able to
integrate that email in with your
twitter and then from there i'll be able
to see you know tweets or or how many
likes for example and to top it off i
can see how many people from around the
world clicked on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links
you can look at social so if i click on
the social tab here if i integrated my
social i can look at social reporting
likewise for e-commerce and notice
analytics 360 i can integrate google
analytics in with mailchimp if i want to
so i have all sorts of options on my
reporting so that's it for mailchimp i
mean it's fairly easy to navigate you
have all the campaigns that you've sent
out so if you just click on campaigns
i'll be able to see all the campaigns
i've set up and all the campaigns that
have been sent and obviously the ones
that have been sent i can start looking
at reports i can pick and choose
templates okay i can pick and choose my
audience and manage my audience okay i
can see what the growth is for my
audience again i have different options
to grow my audience okay i can certainly
add form submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are going to be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to githi's to instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in mailchimp we're going to cover
email marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
so email marketing's traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while and you're going to be asked some
questions that are going to accomplish a
lot of things related to the delivery of
emails we all check emails on a daily
basis we all receive them sometimes we
receive emails unsolicited sometimes we
sign up to receive emails sometimes
receive emails from friends sometimes we
receive emails where we're working or
previously worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're going to get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft balance so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay as spam or something to
that effect so the email server is going
to identify that and it's not even going
to reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so now
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so next question here
what would you do to improve the
click-through rate of your email so
click the rate is simply how many people
have seen your email and how many people
actually clicked on a link in the email
so if 100 people saw your email but only
one person clicked then it would be a
one percent click-through rate so we
want to be able to make sure we have a
high click-through rate so remember
emails are going to people who likely
signed up to receive your email and even
if they are expecting an email or
they're not expecting an email you still
want to follow some of these best
practices here one is to create a
compelling subject line so you want to
make the subject line something that
people are going to notice take note of
or take an interest in and say hey
what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you could send
out the same email twice except one
segment's going to say get one version
of the email the other segment is going
to get another version of the email and
what are the different versions maybe
the subject line so the subject line is
different on version a versus version b
or maybe the call to action is different
so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how are you going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey
you know if it's a software maybe hey
we've got upcoming updates to our
software make sure you go to the website
and get the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more
update upgrade whatever so newsletters
the way to go so again some basic tips
here you want to create your newsletter
with 90 educational and 10 percent
promotional so remember you're sending
out a newsletter to people who likely
signed up so you're educating them about
your products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so
make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products to
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real life example because i used to
work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light
blues you know it wasn't black or dark
red or anything that's going to be you
know heavy we knew who our audience was
and we designed the template accordingly
and of course using compelling images so
for selling baby products you're gonna
put baby product images in there i mean
it's common sense but you'd be surprised
you gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position
because most people are going to look at
that email in a mobile phone okay and
then always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so here's some examples okay
we got you know check out the latest
cosmetics from our new collections
notice the image and notice the call to
action so you can see trendy collections
you know we got some other products you
may want to buy okay five important skin
care products that everyone should have
view more so you always want to have
that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
we already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who balanced it
whether it's a soft bounce a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so
if you have let's just say
20 people open the email and you send it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click-through rate again
pop quiz it's just how many people
actually clicked on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of of the emails you've sent
out a response rate okay so response
rate is the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on the link of
your email campaign and actually
completed an action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on a purchase well you'd
have a one percent response rate and
then a forward rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how to recapture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or a competition and re-engage their
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look i haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend say design always matters
especially knowing that you're talking
to customers who haven't been active
okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that customer's inactivity so you're
going to try and do everything you can
to get that customer back and then you
want to follow a consistent schedule
okay so ideally when you schedule an
email you want to schedule the best time
so you have to know your audience
obviously and then you can always ask
for feedback why are they inactive why
haven't they purchased in a while so the
whole idea here from gamification like
trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so what are the
different ways to segment buyer personas
so again when we talk about segmentation
we're talking about taking a smaller
piece the entire pie so what's one way
to break up that pie if you will by
geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information
with analytics so you know one way is
obviously if somebody's purchased that's
a good way to segment because you know
these people believe in you believe in
your business believe in your product so
the way you can message to somebody
who's purchased before is going to be
different than somebody you don't even
know who they are if they purchased or
not okay so behavioral segmentation to
me is one of the easiest things the
easiest ways to segment your email list
how would you drive repeat customers
through email marketing for the below
scenario okay so this is a pop quiz if
you will again for those of you that got
click-through rate correctly kudos let's
see if you can go two for two here okay
so if you know the answer to this go
ahead and comment below but let's just
say give a few examples of subject lines
to drive engagement for audiences based
on the following so if i had an audience
between 20 and 30 years old that were
female and the product were sandals okay
what would some of your subject lines be
so i'm gonna give you a minute to think
about that and put it in the comment
section below now remember this is an
interview based question so you're gonna
have to think on the spot i'm gonna give
you a minute but if somebody presented
that to you in an interview you need to
be able to you know react fairly quickly
and come up with some really attractive
subject lines here okay so here you go
here's another one uh so give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for 20 to 30 females for
footwear so you got friday sale coming
up buy branded sandals at the lowest
price okay so i like this one because
it's got a strong call to action buy
here you go this is even better because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't beat free
anything including shipping and if it's
50 off i mean these are key things so
you're putting the promotion and
percentage off all in the subject line
so that's really going to grab
somebody's attention weekend sale for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines
they all tend to work because they all
have an element of a best practice in
there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what is a b testing and give
some examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b testing
with subject lines so simply a b testing
when it comes to email marketing it's
just a method to analyze which of the
two email campaign strategies is most
effective right you know you're going to
do it based on open rate you can do it
by saying click rate you can do it based
on response rate and remember you're
putting one version of the email against
another version whether that be the
subject line whether it be the content
call to action whatever so that's
ideally what you're trying to do you're
trying to figure out what works for your
audience that's the end goal for email
for a b testing and email marketing
what's going to work and i would highly
suggest you should always do a b testing
for subject lines always so some of the
variables that you can test again
subject lines okay you always want to
try if you got a promotion hey will the
percentage off work likely it will but
let's test it up against something else
like you know a generic word like
discounts you can always test the design
you can always test the personalization
the preview text you can try out images
call to actions exclusive offers what
particular offer is going to work okay
so if you're testing offers then
obviously that's going to be response
rate if you're testing ctas and that's
going to be click-through rate if you're
testing subject lines that's going to be
open rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so how to prevent email from
getting into spam so if you're an email
marketer this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so that doesn't bode well for
you so most email marketing platforms
like mailchimp or constant contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is hey improve your
open rate remember going back to the
first question second question you want
to have really good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option unsubscribe they could just
report you as spam make sure your emails
work on different devices okay you want
to optimize your images for email make
sure they're not big and they don't fit
on a mobile device okay prefer more text
and fewer images
and then avoid grammatical issues you
want to come across as professional you
don't want somebody looking at your
email like who sent this why you send it
to me i don't want to hear from you
again i'm going to spam you you want to
prevent that and that means a
professional looking email
professional content with a really good
subject line and some imagery to go
along with that hey you may just get
somebody to open that email and get them
to convert that's the idea behind it so
these are ways to prevent somebody from
actually spamming you and then what are
the best practices for email subject
lines so the subject line's the most
probably the most important element in
email marketing so we talked about that
little pop quiz with the sandals
targeting 20 to 30 year old women you
know to me i like the subject line with
the 50 off so that was a number in the
subject line so people can actually see
hey wow i get a whole 50
that works better than just a discount
okay remember one of those other subject
lines had an emoji so don't be afraid to
include emojis in there for example when
i send out emails using you know during
the spring you might want to use flowers
perhaps to signify hey it's spring
winter's over so personalize the subject
lines remember that goes with segmenting
so if you know who your audience is your
your subject lines can be a little bit
more personal okay so opt for title case
subject lines okay so instead of making
it grammatical for example okay you want
to keep your subject lines short and to
the point remember you want to say
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention if you make it long
and drawn out and boring then people
aren't going to open it develop a sense
of urgency like hey we got 50 off
through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just
set yourself up for better performance
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on email marketing full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics governed in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
you